what we know  senior chief kelly is the third member  to be attacked  [Music]  three perps are dead  also killed was his wife  they better hope he doesn't survive  why is that he is more dangerous and  effective  than any man we have in the field  [Music]  he took everything from me  these were foreign attacks on u.s soil  we have to respond  i'm gonna make it right  there's something inside of me that i  can't turn off  a part of me that won't stop for  anything  no remorse  has it occurred to you that perhaps john  kelly  has done something we can't  some situations aren't thinking outside  the box  give me your name you were supposed to  be dead give me your name  [Music]  you